economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando na
daniela bienvenida a la isla más grande
del mundo suspenderá la búsqueda de
petróleo hola qué tal raúl mire el
gobierno de izquierda de groenlandia
dice que basó su decisión en el cambio
climático
allí hay cuatro licencias de exploración
en manos de dos pequeñas empresas que
deben mantener por supuesto pero la idea
es no otorgar más licencias en adelante
aunque no se ha encontrado el petróleo
todavía el servicio geológico de eeuu
estima que podría haber 17 mil 500
millones de barriles de petróleo sin
descubrir y 148 billones de pies cúbicos
de gas natural de allí que en su momento
el ex presidente de donald trump haya
planteado su intención de adquirir la
isla que hoy es un territorio
semiautónomo danés de 57 mil habitantes
aunque no lo logró
las reservas potencialmente vastas
habrían sido vistas por la oposición
como una manera de los isleños de
realizar su sueño de independencia de
dinamarca pero después de que asumió el
gobierno actual tras las elecciones
parlamentarias
y comenzó a cumplir sus promesas
electorales y detuvo los planes para la
extracción de uranio en el sur de la
isla caliente
y medio frío solo ver las imágenes el
congreso de brasil aprobó la ley que
guiará el presupuesto para 2022 aún se
trata de un primer boceto del proyecto
de presupuesto definitivo que deberá ser
remitido al legislativo por el gobierno
de jair bolsonaro a más tardar el 31 de
agosto lo que por ahora se sabe es que
el presupuesto prevé un déficit fiscal
de 33 mil millones de dólares y un
crecimiento del producto interno bruto
del 25 por ciento para el próximo año
entre otros puntos la llamada ley de
directrices presupuestarias prevé una
vasta ampliación de los recursos
destinados a la financiación de las
campañas para las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo año lo que
generó críticas por parte de la
oposición y en américa latina' seguimos
la economía peruana creció un 47.8 por
ciento en el mes de mayo lo hizo en
términos de producción nacional que es
como un termómetro raúl ha anticipado de
lo que va a ser el comportamiento
el producto interno bruto que se mide
trimestral el departamento de
estadística reveló que la actividad
económica subió 19 7% en el acumulado
hasta mayo y casi un 50% solo en el
quinto mes aunque este es un efecto
rebote de hace un año cuando todo estaba
cerrado el resultado estuvo impulsado
principalmente por sectores claves como
la construcción manufactura y minería
pero también por alojamiento y
restaurantes si se compara la producción
de esta actividad con la de hace un año
es cinco veces mayor todo porque el año
pasado pues estaba paralizado así dejan
el club de parís le condonó parte de la
deuda a sudán
primero digamos que es el grupo de parís
o el club de parís es un grupo de 22
naciones que otorgan préstamos a países
necesitados
en este caso sudan al que decidió
condonar le 14 mil 100 millones de
dólares en deudas tras elogiar sus
reformas económicas y sus esfuerzos para
luchar contra la pobreza el club de
parís también reprogramó una deuda
restante de 9 mil 400 millones de
dólares aunque las acreencias
ternas de esta nación africana suman
alrededor de 70 mil millones de dólares
este alivio se produce después de que el
fondo monetario internacional anunciara
hace unos días uno por 1.400 millones de
dólares y que a francia también le
condonará otro por 5 mil millones este
país en raúl trata de recuperar una
maltrecha economía que viene de décadas
atrás aunque pues ahora es tarea del
nuevo gobierno tras el derrocamiento
militar de omar al bachir en 2019 así es
angeli ya para finalizar le pregunto qué
nos tiene hoy como cifra del día 28
millones de dólares mire por este valor
había sido subastado un asiento en el
viaje inaugural al espacio de blue
origin de james besos programado para el
próximo martes 20 de julio sin embargo
el feliz comprador se bajó del vuelo por
problemas de agenda y será reemplazado
por un estudiante de física de 18 años
cuyo padre dirige una empresa de gestión
de inversiones aunque no sé dijo cuánto
pagó por la reventa oliver dime
unirá a la tripulación civil de cuatro
miembros que la completan la piloto
willi funk de 82 años y el
multimillonario dueño de amazon además
de su hermano marc se montaría en ese
viaje especial de por supuesto gratis o
pagando mi montar yo creo que sí paso
daría las muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica a ustedes también gracias
continúen con nosotros
[Música]
e